we use cast iron skillets all the time
in the tasty kitchen for a million
different reasons they're virtually
indestructible they last forever and
unlike a lot of things you're going to
have in your kitchen they actually tend
to get better with age people are often
a little bit intimidated by cast iron
thinking it's you know very hard to deal
with or hard to clean it's actually
really easy you just have to know what
you're looking for
[Music]
so seasoning is a process you want to go
through even if it's new or you have an
old cast iron that was passed down to
you often when you have a new cast iron
and there's been any water that's left
on they're really susceptible to rust
we're going to help you figure out how
to prevent that from happening and how
to clean that off so we're going to
start by getting some steel wool whether
it's new or has a bunch of rust on it
we're just going to scrub it down with
steel wool with a mild dish soap and
just get it down to its kind of base
layer the way that cast irons are made
it's all kind of one piece and you can't
just season the part that you cook with
you want to season the entire thing
while we're here we're just going to
keep scrubbing along all of the sides on
the back of it turn it over get the
handle once you're happy you got all the
rust and or gunk off there you can go
give it a rinse under hot water and
either use one of those non-abrasive
scouring pads or the tough side of a
sponge and just do another little quick
go around making sure you got every nook
and cranny a good rule to remember
whenever you're dealing with cast iron
is water will make it rust we always
want to get it as dry as possible before
we store or move on to the next step so
because of that you're going to dry it
off with a towel and then you're going
to put it onto your stove and turn it on
and let all of that excess water any
extra moisture boil off once you're
happy your skillet is bone dry we're
going to take it off the heat and start
our seasoning process with a thin layer
of oil the new standard is that flax
seed oil is the best oil for the job it
actually dries the hardest and creates
the best non-stick longest lasting
seasoning the only downfall is it is
pretty expensive and if you don't want
to spend that much money or frankly you
just don't have it in your pantry canola
oil will work just fine a little
background on your skillet the surface
is actually porous which just means
there's kind of small holes or pores
even that we kind of want to fill up to
make a nice smooth cooking surface so
once we have this thin layer of oil all
over the skillet we're actually going to
do our best to wipe it all off there's
enough oil that is soaked into those
open pores so take the clean side of
your paper towel and rub off as much of
the oil as you can one of the biggest
problems people have is they don't wipe
off enough oil and they have too thick
of a layer and then it comes out of the
oven very sticky still and not giving
them the result they want so you're
going to put your cast iron in your oven
on the highest temperature it can go
between 450 and 500 degrees so this
process is going to take about an hour
the reason why we need our oven so high
is we actually want to take the oil past
its smoking point so that the oil
actually starts to break down and bond
with the cast iron so if you've ever
taken out your skillet and it's still
kind of brown and sticky it's probably
because your oven wasn't hot enough so
after an hour you can turn off your oven
and let it cool in there the result is a
hard glassy layer that we're looking for
that helps make our cast iron nonstick
so intro to cooking with cast iron you
actually really do have to preheat it it
doesn't necessarily heat evenly but it
keeps the heat really well so just take
your time heat it on a low to medium
heat this may take five to ten minutes
because cast iron is such a great
conductor of heat if you actually just
carefully hover your hand over the
bottom of the skillet you can feel when
the pan's ready to go a lot of people
are confused you know they did all the
seasoning and their food is sticking to
the pan usually that's because they're
putting cold food in a cold cast iron
pan one reason to get a cast iron
skillet really is to sear things like
meat so another thing that people are
maybe confused about when they're
cooking with the cast iron is they tend
to want to just move the food around a
lot and actually what we're trying to do
here is build up a nice caramelized
crust so when you put any meat in your
hot skillet just leave it let it cook
and when you see the kind of brown crust
forming on the outside that's when you
know it's ready to flip so if you're
trying to lift up your steak and it just
will not give it's probably that's not
ready yet the meat will self-release
when that crust has formed why we love
using cast iron skillet to tasty too is
because you can start something on the
stove and finish it in the oven so you
often hear that you can't cook acidic
foods and in cast iron skillets however
if you have a good layer of seasoning on
there that's totally fine you don't want
to do a ton of no big tomato sauce or a
bunch of wine or vinegar but a little
bit's not really going to kill your
seasoning don't be afraid to roast
things like tomatoes in your cast iron
skillet the great thing about being able
to cook with something on the stove top
and finish it in the oven is you just
have a lot more control you can get a
nice layer of caramelization from a high
heat on the stove and then finish
something cooking in the oven on a much
gentler radiant heat
so when you're cleaning your cast iron
you want to hit a sweet spot if it's
cooled down too much the food will
adhere and really stick to the pan if
it's too hot and you put it under cold
water you can risk it cracking so you
want to wash the pan pretty soon after
you use it the most gentle way to clean
your skillet is with hot water and salt
and a non-metal scouring pad or the
rough side of your sponge the salt works
as an abrasive and helps to scrub off
any food that's on there without
damaging the seasoning at all once
you're happy that your pan is clean give
it another towel dry and then let it
completely dry off either on the stove
or in a warm oven just to make sure
there's no lingering moisture and that's
going to protect it from rusting in the
future so lastly we're going to put a
protective layer of oil on the skillet
before we store it carefully with the
paper towel rub that all along the
inside turn up the heat until the oil is
smoking then turn it off and let it cool
on the stove the reason why we want to
take it out to the smoking point is so
that the oil doesn't turn rancid
cast iron skillets may seem like a lot
of work but just follow these simple
rules of seasoning and cleaning and
these pans will last you a lifetime
it's like loving a good woman the more
you give
the more you get back